L'aventure étrangère The Last of Us se déroule 20 ans
après qu'une épidémie très spécifique s'est produite
qui implique un champignon ce champignon est réel
s'il devait pouvoir infecter les humains,
cela irait comme si c'était terrifiant les
virus peuvent nous rendre malades mais les champignons peuvent
altérer notre très  Ne pense
pas à agir Joel est un homme brisé c'est un
père qui a subi une perte Je ne
sauve pas la vie de Sarah qui est la fille de Joel
qui est l'événement qui façonne
le personnage pour le reste de sa vie
un contrebandier du marché noir qui est chargé
d'un travail de  transporter cette
fille de 14 ans nommée Ellie dans ce
groupe militaire qui donne l'espoir à l'humanité de
développer un vaccin
lorsque vous adaptez quelque chose comme un
jeu vidéo, les changements doivent être faits
intelligemment, nous en disons plus, il y a
tellement de choses entre les deux, puis-je avoir  une arme à feu non je
ne suis pas on m'a conseillé de ne pas jouer le jeu
mais je l'ai juste regardé le jeu jouer
là
secrètement va être beau terrifiant Mais
finalement c'est éclairant lui
rend justice et puis  certains